nós vamos testar aqui o nosso lazer com
a fifa ae
o pessoal aqui quem fala é dar que sejam
muito bem vindos à emel mostrado de que
mais um vídeo do laser eu mas gente eu
acho que vou jantar ó porquê e tarde e
eu tô com fome eo prefeito e vamos
mostrar os meus poderes psíquicos que
mora lá pessoal usar o poder também
projetar olha aí qual participa até
agora vamos abrir o lula me está a ficar
fraca mas ainda dá pra jogar água e uma
colher na época em pleno ano o feijão
vai ser a parte mais difícil ter um
chevrolet hall o g1 chegou outro lado
não estão também a me cansar
o filme up e agora pessoalmente exige
mais trabalho e mais trabalho da minha
mente poderosa foi colher vêm até mim
[Música]
muito boa por aí agora toda hora você
gostou e agora sim agora sim posso fazer
ouvir e como vocês puderam ver um título
hoje vamos fazer laser contra pisapia
inep se é que já não está inteiro né
enquanto começa pequeno almoço pensei
por que não tentar fatiar uma fonte da
pisa o laser por aí vai a pergunta é
possível fatiar pizza com isso foi uma
ideia minha e eu tento aos vossos
comentários já tô vendo que você já não
agüenta e tem umas idéias muito boas que
eu vou fazer em vídeo então se tiverem
alguma ideia boa comentei é possível
qualquer coisa e eu vou fazer o vídeo já
sabe se vocês forem novos aqui no canal
esq lei não se deixem muito leve que
neste vídeo já sabem que só a tv eo
cinema é porque o guarani estar mais
vídeos que vocês não podem perder nada
porque vai ser e vídeo que nunca ninguém
fez aqui no youtube é preparar se para o
conteúdo que é r
mas antes de passarmos a pista tem
muitas outras coisas para tentar deter e
executar então vamos a eles foram lá não
só a primeira coisa que eu tenho aqui
são os potinhos de boi do banheiro e uma
cozinha eu acho chato mesmo assim e
assim dá pra fazer muita coisa bonecos
personagens muita coisa eu vou tentar
fazer alguns médicos tentaram capital
escutar o pescoço cortado brasil é muito
do meu corpo agora estou o tronco do que
vai mexer os braços
layse e agora vamos sentar da capital
cortar aqui circula e 321 vai jogos
proteção já sabem pessoal segurança
acima de tudo não façam isso em casa vai
rolar a iju tocar diretamente na cabeça
e deu e não acontece nada
o poodle é muitas vezes tentou executar
vamos entrar no mar ela então olha o
personagem que vamos fazer só essa é mó
como tanto aí é uma super minhoca
este não está multando por ter que fazer
uma língua é pra lá que vai da fumaça
sol ficou curiosa já que ficou mais
corrida já que eu acho que ficar aqui à
noite pela câmara só se tiver alguma
coisa comentei porque nem toda pra lá
não aconteça aí quando se os sintomas
não se conseguem ver mas ali dentro
ficou mais curva 10 já sabem ler ou
existem dólares não só a próxima coisa
que nós vamos tentar deter são balões
eu sei que eu já tentei imitar um banco
em êxtase mas o que nós vamos fazer hoje
é fazer uma fila era de bombons a uns
quatro ou cinco longe vamos ver se
consegue aumentar os quatro balões
juntos eu acho que vai conseguir mas
vamos tentar para eu só está com um eu
não sei se está forte o suficiente ainda
iam não está aí vamos tentar com dois
juntos 31 vai ao jantar
a encosta no fundo da ai meu deus não
está pra ser um ovo está muito iluminado
dilma é muito fácil tem um colégio em
dois formatos não estava mais lá três
balões 48 e vou tentar fazer uma fila de
quatro valores que vamos ver quanto é
conhecido ambiental mesmo tempo que
vamos contar o tempo eu acho que deve
demorar de quatro segundos aumentaram
quase um segundo por cada dólar o que
vocês acham que eu tenho só a parte mais
chata em tiros boi vai ficar assim ela
vai ficar aí não vai falar um segundo
milagre só vou tentar aguentar aquele
carro com balão quais longe longe e faz
o quarto ataque e quatro balões é chato
em fila eu vou colocar mais e vamos ver
enquanto o segundo já que o documento só
vou começar a contar a partir de agora
321 vai 23 45 segundos e argumentar
quatro balões uma distância de frente
porque o dia aumentando a distância e
dois deles fugiram da sua linha portanto
eu acho que dava banho quatro segundos
eu acho que sim acho que sim só se
quiserem ver no próximo vídeo quantos
balões é que o laser com segmentar em
fila não é tem muito aí posso escrever
esse filho porque eu também acho que é
fazer
imaginem só tem uma fila de 100 boa
noite e 120 aguentar todos não é
cachorro come dancing quiserem ver esse
vídeo mas antes antes de fazer um desvio
eu vou tentar fazer uma coisa é ainda
maior com balão
vejam só que eu tinha que falar eu
perguntando onde eu
a companhia tinha uma coisa especial mas
já nos ataques o alvejou só que eu tenho
aqui olha o tamanho desse balão ou é
muito grande é gigante e o que eu vou
fazer eu vou enchê lo agora e vamos ver
silva às vezes consegue aguentar este
balão é porque isso não é bem mais
resistente a lei bem grosso e pelo leão
china plástico ó opel é muito resistente
sério e vamos mais tempo só agora
não vai ter estudo campo é porque eu
quisesse encher o estudo com a boca e
ficar aqui muito tempo portanto eu vou
contar com a ajuda da nossa amiga é
super superior é de ar oxigenado olha
ainda não está ligado basicamente estão
com professores só para muito além e
vamos tentar repetir o bom começo é por
não sei se vocês lembram mas já usei
isso pra tirar furinho miguel monteiro
não comunitários e do uol só uma
curiosidade não acredito que vamos ligar
a história é só ligar aqui ó
agora vai com muita calma vai tá ligado
vejam só 31 vai sozinha farinha vou
tentar investir um valor que 321 vai
pícoli currículo assim só podem ver isso
muito rápido para lá tentar este disse
que isso é bem grande para lançou 321
vai muito grande sábio na frente mais
fora três jornais a cópia do documento
porque é exatamente aí eu acho que é o
momento de comprar aqui já que se é
suficiente olha só o tamanho desse bolão
está na perseguição mas é muito grande e
que deixou também de mr
a lei é muito grande subir no meu ouvido
fica surdo e sei que tem tanto ar que
parecendo etapa o chamado assim por cima
temos aqui um nó também é jorge para
quem sou eu parece que tem dentro porque
demora muito tempo tinha já só 123
levantar o pó demora muito tempo
possível derrotar os fundos para 3 21 12
na qual bateu no teto para 3 1 1 1 2 3 4
5 e agora vamos tentar apontar o laser
aquino balão e vamos ver se arrebenta eu
acho alimentar vai fazer um bolo gigante
ainda por cima que já está no youtube só
o tratado domingo eu acho que o joão
cuidar com estudos nos disse que me
interessa porque estou fazendo o vietnã
malávi deixar aqui o balão em cima da
cama e eu vou tentar apontar o laser é
que quando você só vou ficar aqui todos
estão prontos para laser contra balão em
381 vai só para os amigos
deixa eu tenho que fazer uma pausa que
foi muito intenso e vou tentar disparar
12 e lá atrás eu acho que daqui vai
parar suas 32 eo vai e ela é muito
resistente sua lei do fluido estuda
vamos tentar mais perder um boy como
ficou o balão olha aí olha só ficou
expressa rebentou sumiu
só aí o filhote de lobo bem mas morrer
a derrubar o benê ouviram um barulho bem
fofo 31 vai é muito fofo barulho só
agora imaginem uma fila era de balões
gigantes de 100 bilhões mas nem só
imagine ficar só de mim
será que vou fazer este vídeo será será
muitas coisas que vocês perguntaram
muito foi daqui que será com uma lupa
consegue identificar o laser pelo med eu
acho que não consegue porque ja tentei
muitas vezes e nunca funcionou fosse
raios solo eu acho que lula conseguiu
unir os cachos sol e formar um ponto
único de machucar como mas já tem isso e
eu acho que acontece nada pessoal não
acontece nada acho que ainda faz pior
acho que ele dispensa mais longe não é
isso que o povo fica um pouco maior aqui
vamos próximo pelo coc ae quase porque o
meu pai quase que em cima do muro de
outra coisa que eu tenho aqui brutal
esse papel este que pode parecer um
papel mal né
olha aí é só uma folha de papel comum
mas não é pessoal que tem uma folha
muito especial e vamos mostrar eu vou
arrancar um pouquinho e vocês vão ver o
efeito é brutal 321 vai isaf não
acontece nada era uma pessoa calma
acontece você está vendo isso têm
dificuldade em queimar coisas brancas
porco branco não absorvemos banco o
branco reflete a luz eo prefeito é este
papel é absorver mais então o que nós
vamos fazer vamos fazer aqui uma pinta
preta jardim gabineto vou fazer aqui uma
pinta preta por ela só 31 vai aparecer
só vocês viram o papel do fogo
completamente desapareceu o total foi de
futebol mas é bem perigoso portanto não
se instala em casa sério só usar porque
já estou muito habituado e eu já
brinquei muito com ela portanto eu
sempre vou fazer inclusive joguei
algumas vezes correu por isso é que eu
vou avisar muito portanto não brinquei
mesmo com ela em casa o que vamos fazer
aqui uma pinta preta
olha aí pinta por lá 321 vai mais uma
vez o hotel é muito bonito porque
desaparece completamente no ar é bom mas
não faço da folha é bem grande e isso
vai ajudar muito importante vou tirar
bem ao por lá a 321 vai brasil no ano e
não será nada incrível não só depois de
meia hora que já chegaram e agora sim
nós vamos testar aqui o nosso lazer com
a pisa 30 almoço um piso carlos minc
solo
é mesmo pra casa não dá pra ver já que
quase tudo mas o país só tem que se
discutir espero que essa expressão mas
elas ainda estão juntos e eu vou tentar
atingir kula sérvia que não mas vamos
ver se eu conseguir ter o casco de ter o
pão poder ter todos os ingredientes que
custará pisa no meio você faz voltar só
o que fazer já só é possível faturar uma
pisa colégio me dei e sim ou não paga
ninguém lá pessoal espera espero um dois
três contigo tempo pessoal e vamos lá
estar aqui pra lá só estão prontos mas
serviços pisa blá 321 vai ocorrer só
semana pisa crettaz irá ao golfo já o
bota se fundasse fu não se conseguem ver
aí que eu quero fazer é mais ou menos
assim não fosse criar aresta pisa ok ok
o clipe só porque o estado tem é que dá
pra ver o que está do teu vou tentar
ficar aqui um ponto da costa costa
quando será assinado e os criam a 111
aproveite e começa a atingir a boa visão
só seja um piso como embaixo prisa mas
só quem gosta não precisa nem preciso
não perder a bola mais uma vez 31 vai
elaborar acho que não vai dar em nada
porque apesar da história do tiro que
esta pista é muito grossa mesmo tem
muito que a gente tem muita massa tem
muito tudo vai ser bem difícil para a
nossa pisa se uma pessoa quiser uma pisa
mais fina 85 chega timbu então será pisa
esturricado também gosto e 50 vai dizer
se uma pisada uma massa mais fina eu
acho que tava pra cortar mas assim assim
não sei o que é isso não só gostava que
fosse sem desistir empate para chegar
àquela pisa queimada mas não é queimada
tipo estava em mim no ponto sabem qual
vamos tentar mostrar aqui para isso
olha só a sua fraca tinha pisado a loja
já está no ponto uma coisa que reparei é
que o laser não for útil à nossa pisa
mas também no centro ontem que o risco
que está detido para isso a facilidade
com que os petistas passaram da primeira
que os beat e agora faço a pergunta
novamente você já que responder a isso é
possível faturar uma pisa colega isso
foi considerado um sim ou não comentei
mas claro eu não vou deixar ficar por
aqui porque já encomendei mais leve e
portanto vou tentar juntar muitos mas
acho que depois possa pedir só se
quiserem claro imaginei cinco anos
juntos e tentar forjar uma pisa eu acho
que é possível mas aí pessoal o vídeo
vai ficar preguiça pra assistir nenhum
estado já sabem como tem mais coisas que
vocês queiram ver com
o tipo é possível essa é a nova série no
canal exclusivo aqui no canal da frame
manthey é possível qualquer coisa eu
estabeleci idéia eu vou fazer já sabem
deixe muito laquê que não estive por que
se ponha muita que o canal que faz o
show novos aqui no canal que subscrevam
também para não perderem nenhum vídeo já
sabem que em cima vocês vão poder ver
mais dois filhos muito divertidos mesmo
eu garanto por excluir lá e aqui embaixo
vocês podem se inscrever aqui no canal e
só fiquem vai até a próxima